hurricane Ian blew in off the Florida
coast and landed here only days ago it
will take years to repair the state that
buckled under Brute Force
[Music]
having seen the back of the hurricane
here they now struggle through its
aftermath
[Music]
buddy give you the right to jump the
lines
I'm gonna have to ask you to pull that
away the stress was on display at the
garage four Court can I give you all the
move please I don't think so there's a
shortage of fuel in a place where the
motor car is king and the pumps queues
are counted by the kilometer as a
population blinks back into the sunlight
After the Storm without it I don't have
AC or any way to cook
um it's uh we have to have it to live
right now this is the worst we've ever
seen uh this is the worst we've ever
seen here
um this is
I mean everything's it's unsurmountable
this was my first hurricane so this has
been quite a quite a humbling experience
this is the Renaissance Preserve in Lee
County in one corner of this
neighborhood it's life as they knew it
in another
it's life as they know it now it's a
crisis we have shortage of everything
this is the long and winding road to
emergency supplies of dried food water
and ice a military operation people are
very desperate
um we've we've had people come come up
to our sites uh begging
crying lost everything we feel for them
after hitting Florida hurricane Ian
moved on elsewhere on America's
southeast coast
by then downgraded to a category 1 storm
this was how it looked upon landing on
South Carolina
in Florida it's gone but not forgotten
before the hurricane hit San Carlos RV
resort was home to Luxury Motor Homes
and residents relaxing by the shore
now the concrete Bears lie empty because
the motorhomes lie upside down and 200
yards across the bay
everywhere you look are the remnants of
Life laid there put into words if you
can what you've lost here everything I
mean the properties here that's the
value but for us the value is our
customers and it's just devastating to
everybody the death toll from Hurricane
Ian continues to rise as search teams
work through reports of missing people
and check properties around the state so
they find more fatalities
it's a process that could last for
months the destruction of hurricane Ian
is here and now for all to see
calculating the human cost will take
longer
James Matthews Sky News and Fort Myers
Florida